I'm standing outside La Corona it is one
of the premier cigar factories here in
Cuba they're assembled by about 400
workers and each one is an artist
it takes them nine months to master the
craft of making a cigar here I'm gonna
go inside and check it out it's very
cool that we get to do this
this is dine ma'am I sing your name
correctly yes they need the furni
awesome the marketing and communication
are specialists Frank Havana to say this
is luck Corona this is what they make
Corona yes
look at that and it's all handmade
everything is totally nice man Wow and
how many cigars do you think are made
here a day come on twenty-five thousand
seven cigars per unit is it possible for
me as a gift to get twenty five thousand
Havana cigars today to take home with me
this is a gift you see your tone was yes
but you said no
does it take to learn how to roll a
cigar if I were to work here these are
the nine months of one year if I brought
my own herbs medicinal herbs from
California could I roll them here
hola me llamo Conan O'Brien soy una
estrella Gigante a los Estados Unidos
you say que estoy muy animals ever made
salad army if possible maintain a brass
army especialmente las mujeres
[Music]
who knows hombre sales and dollars
Tamia prepared a Leo
Santos wearing the Kyoto macchiato I am
from America and I wish to bring you as
a gift our finest cigars that we make
these are white out
owl cigars there are Cinco five of them
you may divide them up amongst
yourselves we're gonna kiss him yes
right where were you sure this is really
cool
yummy let is now going to show me how to
make an authentic Cuban cigar better
that okay perfecto la Pinta this is the
filler say I don't made you fold I like
the way you fold it okay otere good
right what was all that when you bring
it this way as you roll it
Wow look at that I got to this stage and
I stick it right in here
I just watched you and I've mastered it
I can do it we break it down the middle
okay yeah and then that comes off there
right then here I watched you I think
that's what you did my way is good we
got that I get this hold it
let's get the inspector please hello
this is the inspector can I show you
what's wrong with it it's a cigar come
on
No
baby she's now inspecting that cigar you
know like that one no made a girlfriend
they'd use this on me
she was not happy
actually it was a little more likely
Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's only been a few days but I've
already grown very fond of Cuba and I
think the feeling is mutual
[Applause]